[Musique]
c'est la chose qui me passionne de plus
rien qui me draguent autant que le ciel
leur est ingénieur l'autre préposés à
l'entretien dans le milieu hospitalier
récemment cédrick desjardins et
répondent ses gains se sont lancé le
défi de fabriquer des planches à
roulettes comme un bon background
technique
je travaille dans l'aéronautique puis
je sais pas ça j'avais comme un instinct
pour savoir comment le faire à partir de
la recherche ils ont construit leur
propre presse puis ont élaboré leur
modèle de prisches c'est un stick et
nick roulant j'ai une petite entreprise
artisanale les moyens de faire pas mal
n'importe quoi qu'on veut en fait défaut
gpro vis du truc et pour eux pas
question de faire venir du matériel prix
construit à l'international ça fait
aucun sens au niveau environnemental
puis surtout du fait que je suis moi
dans ma taille je me disais quand par
une compagnie il faut que tu te mettre
les deux mains d'un
les jeunes entrepreneurs contrôle
chacune des étapes de la production mais
pour le reste il se laisse porter par la
vague je me crée aucune attente depuis
le début que je pense c'est ce qui fait
que ça fonctionne et ce soir les
cofondateurs de croulants explose
jackalope parmi les géants d'industrie
de saison estivale des sports extrêmes
commence à se faire demander pour des
projets compagne et des gens qui veulent
être désigné des skate ou à l'erreur
mais jamais quelque chose d'aussi rouxel
chaque occasion de se faire connaître
est essentiel pour des petites
entreprises comme l'indiquent maïka des
forges producteur exécutif de
l'événement parce que ça fait partie
l'écosystème de jackalope mettre la
lumière sur des passionnés dont ses
jalons pour que soient visibles faut que
tu batista marque puis ça bah oui c'est
un chemin sacchi qui ne fait que
commencer il faut éventuellement faire
évolué d'année en année même si je te
considèrent eux-mêmes comme la relève
vincent et cédric pense déjà à aider
d'autres passionnés à percer le milieu
que je me dis si je peux commencer des
jeunes puisque saint yves est une
dépense pour les parents que plus comme
abordé skate comme ils veulent puissent
pas être obligés d'attendre après ben je
trouve que c'est mieux les deux
fondateurs des croulants ne veulent pas
se mettre de pression mais se donne le
droit de rêver si je peux gagner ma vie
avec ça ce serait ça serait l'idéal
ici alexandre a piqué radio canada
montréal